Pixar has spent years making films that are
enjoyable to kids and adults alike.
From Toy Story to Coco, the studio has become
a favorite of moviegoers of all ages.
Onward is no exception to the rule, building
a magical kid-friendly adventure in between
some pretty adult topics and jokes.
Onward follows Ian and Barley Lightfoot as
they try to bring back their dad from the
dead for a single day in order to get to know
him.
Unfortunately, Ian only brings back the bottom
half of their dad, leading to a quest to find
a magic gem that can bring back his upper
half before he completely fades away at sundown.
As the two and a half men go about their urgent
quest, there's plenty of Weekend at Bernie's-esque
shenanigans and magical mixups to delight
the kids.
However, adults might find themselves wondering
why the movie's main story is about two kids
bonding with their dad's butt.
As Uproxx's Mike Ryan so eloquently summarized:
"This is a movie about two kids resurrecting
their dead dad's crotch and it's just the
WEIRDEST thing."
While Pixar has managed to stay beloved over
the years, other animation studios have stepped
up their game.
Disney's non-Pixar animation studio brought
the world Frozen and Tangled, while DreamWorks
had a massive franchise hit on its hands with
How to Train Your Dragon.
Still, even as other studios have begun to
match Pixar's artistry, Pixar movies feel
unique, with an incomparable sense of style
and personality that shines through.
Until Onward, that is.
The 2020 movie feels like Pixar slapped a
logo over a DreamWorks film, from the character
designs to the dancing sequence in the middle.
In fact, "Onward looks like a DreamWorks movie"
was a common refrain when the trailer first
dropped.
While it might not go so far as to have a
dance sequence as the credits roll, that might
not stop some adults from briefly forgetting
which studio made Onward.
About halfway through Onward, Ian and Barley
Lightfoot get pulled over by some fantasy
cops.
One, a cyclops played by Lena Waithe, offhandedly
mentions her "girlfriend's daughter."
It's a small moment for a character that really
only shows up in a very small scene.
Still, adults will likely catch the implication
that Waithe's character is gay.
However, considering the brief screen time
for the character, and the even briefer mention
of the character's girlfriend, it's unlikely
that children will catch the meaning.
It's wonderful that Disney is acknowledging
the existence of LGBTQ+ people in the world
of their films, but like the brief lesbian
kiss in Star Wars: The Rise of Skywalker,
these moments tend to be fairly insubstantial.
Hopefully, the existence of people along a
gender and sexual spectrum won't be something
that only adults notice in films going forward.
In one notable set piece, Ian and Barley have
to figure out a way to cross a bottomless
pit in order to continue their quest.
Barley tells Ian about a spell that will let
him walk on air by creating an invisible bridge
that continues to exist as long as he truly
believes in it.
The safety rope falls away while Ian's halfway
across, but he's already got the confidence
to cross the bridge by himself and doesn't
notice.
Children might be on the edge of their seats
hoping that Ian makes it across, but the whole
scene will likely feel very familiar to the
adults watching.
The whole set piece feels a bit like team-building
exercises like the "trust fall" or walking
on hot coals - or the invisible bridge Indiana
Jones had to walk across in The Last Crusade.
For the majority of the runtime of Onward,
viewers are likely empathizing with Ian's
quest to get to know his dad.
He's the character who seems most outwardly
affected by his father's death, and he's the
one who seems most eager to bring him back
as soon as possible.
Near the end of the film, however, Barley
reveals that he has deep regrets over not
getting the chance to say goodbye to his dad
before he passed away.
During the scene, the adults in the audience
might realize that Barley's voice actor, Chris
Pratt, has some practice playing an aging
man-child struggling to get over the traumatic
death of a parent due to a sudden sickness.
After all, that describes Barley just as well
as it describes Peter Quill in the Guardians
of the Galaxy movies.
"Star lord."
"Who?"
"Star Lord, man, legendary outlaw?"
Even though Onward is ostensibly set in the
"modern" world with touchscreen cell phones,
there's a distinctly '80s sensibility to the
environment.
Barley drives a van with a fantasy decal on
the side, plays a game similar to Dungeons
& Dragons, and both Ian and Barley listen
to cassette decks instead of streaming music
or even CDs.
Even their mother Laurel gets her exercise
by watching a workout tape.
As The Atlantic's David Sims wrote in his
review:
"Onward is informed by the '80s aesthetic
of tabletop games, minivans airbrushed with
heavy-metal album-cover art, and cookie-cutter
suburban life..."
While plenty of kids wouldn't even recognize
a cassette, nostalgic adults might recall
their own days playing Dungeons & Dragons
and listening to '80s power ballads - or at
least watching films that reference those
moments.
Plot holes don't tend to matter much in a
world that literally has magic in it.
Still, there are some rules to the magic in
Onward, and one moment near the end of the
film may leave adults scratching their heads.
During the battle with the dragon, Ian loses
his dad's magical staff, but manages to make
his own by enlarging a splinter that had gotten
stuck in his hand earlier in the film.
In the epilogue, Ian can be seen giving a
talk to a group of students as he stands with
his magical splinter staff.
However, earlier in the film, it's established
that Barley's accidental shrinking because
of the spell misfiring is temporary.
While kids are enjoying the epilogue, adults
might be wondering whether objects made larger
are also temporary, or whether that only applies
to shrunk objects.
If Ian can make things permanently larger,
does this lead to a Cloudy With a Chance of
Meatballs-type situation?
Or does Ian just grow his splinter whenever
he wants to use his staff?
Can anyone explain this?
"Please to explain this?"
"Well, whenever you notice something like
that, a wizard did it."
"I see, alright, yes, but in episode AG4-"
"Wizard."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.